we have a discussion forum for our
viewers for our listeners for people who
maybe do neither but just like to
discuss politics online and it's the
david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT I am still
in the midst of negotiating what I'm
going to be doing at Politico next month
and there was a post that I saw on the
subreddit outlining this person this
posters sort of like wishlist fantasy
face off which would be a five-on-five
debate where on the Left we would have
Genki augur ana kasparian kyle kolinsky
of secular talk fame me and then Sam
cedar debating and I don't know who 2/3
of these people are debating on the
right Ben Shapiro who I know
Alysha Kraus who I don't know Andrew
Klavan or Clavin who I don't know
Michael Knowles who I don't know and
then Charlie Kirk I am familiar with I
don't know how you do a five-on-five
debate with these people it would need
to be like a 10 hour debate that would
be pretty messy Alicia Krause Andrew
Clavin and Michael no Knowles are all on
Ben Shapiro's network ok the daily wire
there are posts on that channel so ok
yeah I think you come up with some
better names on the right like really
you know steven crowder some other
prominent ones I have a store I can't I
you know sometimes I kind of play coy
with things I can and can't say I I have
a story about steven crowder and
engaging in debate with strong debaters
from the left that I hope I can someday
tell ok let me put it that way and I'm
not even gonna speculate because it's
it's just can't talk I really can't talk
about it but it's a story I am hoping at
some point can be discussed i think
steven crowder prefers debating college
kids who are particularly informed on
the issues he's prepared to debate so
that's more his wheelhouse so listen
I'll talk about my wheelhouse which is
unclear because I still don't know what
I'm doing at Politico so I as I know I
will tell you join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash re d di t